got a question for you so last night
Robert's with us you know Robert's
always got a different lens r o yeah R
so the entire time I'm like why do they
keep going to Tim Scott and I kept
turning around I W like the guys this
guy on 2.0 he speaks too slow like it's
like we just noticed it upstairs we
watching him on 2. on YouTube and it's
like as if he's
list the anti you show up the CNN
numbers can you show up the CNN numbers
check this out who spoke the most and
the least okay okay the most last night
was Tim Scott and then Haley and then VC
and then Des Sanz and then Christie okay
I understand Christie why the hell would
Tim Scott speak the most so then Rob
says maybe
because NBC is doing it intentionally to
make the show be so boring that
Americans don't watch it age okay maybe
it was an intentional way of getting
people say I can't listen to this
anymore move away do you think NBC is
that dumb to realize that in a business
of capitalism if your sponsors that are
paying you millions of dollars don't get
a lot of eyeballs are going to be okay
with you giving it to the person like
what what the audience wants to see a
fight between Haley and Vic put the top
three the top three should have been who
Haley the santis and vivec Tim Scott
should be all the way at the bottom even
below christe is where he should have
been I agree do you think there was any
motives in giving them Scott the most
eyeballs absolutely because I don't
think the producers and the political
writers and the political commentators
and Lester hold himself I don't think
they give a rip on this particular show
what the corporate guys are are looking
at in terms of AD dollars they're going
to promote it they're going to get the
best viewership they can but if they I
think if they detect momentum in that
show they will go away from the momentum
and I I felt like didn't it feel like
that after s minutes they kind kind of
pulled away from VC and they they also
said also unlike other debates if
someone says your name or makes an
accusation you do not get an automatic
30 seconds remember that they did say
that beginning yes they they were saying
that almost trying to kind of control
the flow and so I I think they
absolutely gamed it a little bit I agree
100% And like Brandon was talking about
polls Pat I don't listen to any any
polls the same polls that had Hillary at
99% Pat you're a Democrat let me ask you
a question right now you're a registered
Democrat lifelong Trump hating whatever
it's going to be tough going to be hard
so Pat you saw this debate in that lens
as a Democrat out of everybody here who
would you want if you had to pick if you
if you had to be like all right I'll
deal with this so you want a weak team
to play in the Super Bowl well that b
basically what I'm saying is p because
they know like Biden whatever Chris
Christie would be my number one yeah
Chris Christie would be one because he
hates Trump and I if I'm a Democrat I
want to hear anybody that's trashing
Trump the most it's ham then who I would
probably want to hear is Haley because
she's at least a woman so and her
position on pro-life pro-choice is the
best one amongst everybody then I would
probably Listen to Tim Scott then I
would probably listen to the santis and
Vic would be the most annoying person on
that stage if I'm a Democrat yeah 100%
And then or no 1,00% 1,00% I would fully
agree with you I would just swap VC and
DeSantis I don't think Democrats have
any love for DeSantis well you don't
think so over mon
the only I put via at the top is because
Democrats can't stand capitalist you
know made your own money calling out
anti-establishment the stist
didn't even that day when we had him on
the podcast I said look you're like a
hybrid you could some people think
you're establishment you know and and
that's kind of where you are he didn't
really correct me and even in my intro
he corrected me twice so that is the one
area he didn't correct me about
establishment he just kind of let that
one go you were going to say something
Tom yeah I think I think with the
Democrats don't want they do not want
successful people of color they want
entitled people of color full stop they
don't want successful people of color no
they don't want to go against VC VC
becomes a symbol sense not no yeah the
becomes exactly what they don't want so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right
here